in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 6 on which we commemorate the Holy New Hyromarder
Maximus Sandovich of Poland, St. Maximus Sandovich was born in the year 1886 in the village
of Shdenia on the present frontier of Poland with Slovakia in territory which was part of
the Austro-Hungarian Empire at the time.
His piety was evident from his early years.
As a schoolboy, he would get up early to read the services and sing the canticles of the
church in his room.
He wanted to become a priest or monk, and so at the end of his secondary education, he
entered a uniyat monastery of the region as a novice.
But the life of this establishment soon disappointed him, and he left after three months for
the monastery of Polkaev in Ukraine.
As much renowned for the strictness of its steepicon and for the spiritual life of the fathers,
as for its witness to the Orthodox tradition.
In Maximus was still a novice, Metropolitan Anthony Karpovitsky in the years 1863 through
1936, visited the monastery and asked the abbot to let him take a novice with him, who could
be put to study in his seminary, with a view toward a nation to serve the Ukrainian communities
in the Carpathian region that had returned to Orthodoxy from the unia.
Maximus was chosen so he had to give up his heart's desire for the monastic life, and
follow the bishop.
When he had finished his studies at the seminary in Zitomid, he married a Belorussian wife
and was ordained by the Metropolitan in the year 1911.
His pastoral ministry began in the town of Grab, not far from his native village, where
he served the first Orthodox liturgy since the Carpathian Russians yielded to uniotism
in the 18th century.
He was arrested on a visit to his family home, sentenced to eight days imprisonment, and
heavily fined.
Father Maximus was unshaken by this and continued to serve the divine liturgy in the surrounding
villages, despite the penalties imposed by the courts upon himself and those who assisted
him.
In March of the year 1912, he was remanded in custody at Lavov, charged with being Orthodox,
using church books written in Russian, and of collaborating with the enemy.
For so, Russia was regarded by the Austro-Hungarian authorities.
Despite the lying accusations heaped up against him, and the ill-treatment and harassment
of all kinds that he endured, when he and his companions came to trial in June, in the
year 1914, they were acquitted.
In poor health, he was able to return to Shdenia, but on the outbreak of the First World
War in August, he was again arrested, together with his pregnant wife, his father, and the
Orthodox of his village.
They were imprisoned at Gorlice, the county town.
On the 6th of September, in the year 1914, Father Maximus was brought out of his cell
before a judge, who summarily informed him that he was condemned to death.
He was shot in the prison yard, before the eyes of the assembled Orthodox prisoners.
As he fell, Christ's valiant martyr cried out.
Long live Holy Orthodoxy.
Whereupon one of the executioners seized with anger, rushed forward, and stabbed him.
It was not until the year 1922 that his body could be taken to Shdenia, where it was laid
to rest near the church.
From then on pilgrims flocked to his tomb.
Veneration of Saint Maximus, as the very image of their ethnic and religious identity, grew
among the Carpathian-Russian Orthodox, especially during the years of their deportation.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.